so hi everyone my name is nemanja
and i'll be talking today about
webassembly and especially for
enterprise
developers so we'll see what that means
and how you can use webassembly in your
next project
so first question is actually what is
web assembly or uh
known as bassm so let's see the
definition it says that the web assembly
is a binary instruction format for a
stack based virtual machine
and when you see that definition you
guys are probably like oh
what does that mean you know it sounds
very confusing i i don't i don't know
what it is
so let's see a very kind of simplified
um
explanation for web assembly so let's
compare it actually
to js because it's uh they run together
in the browser so we want to see how
they compare and
why is one better than the other so when
you have some js code right
and when this loads in in your browser
it's picked up by the browser engine
and the browser engine then actually
needs to first of all parse your code
then it needs to compile it and then
it's executed on your cpu
so i said this is very simplified there
are also a lot of intermediary steps
but broadly this is what happens in your
browser when you load
some javascript files and
how does web assembly fair compared to
that
so when you load webassembly into your
browser engine
it immediately executes so why is that
well i kind of go back to the same
definition here but i've
highlighted the binary instruction
webassembly is a binary format
and this means that it's actually
already pre-compiled parsed and
everything
and it's just ready to run in your
browser
so what do we get by this what are what
are some benefits from web assembly well
first of all as you saw
it's it's very efficient because we
already pre-compiled stuff
and this also means that it's very fast
because the browser itself
doesn't have to do all these steps of
parsing compiling and all this all that
all these things
you can just immediately run when i say
portable i really mean that it's
portable because web assembly is not a
format which is only built by the
browser it can also run in node and it
can also
run in some other environment as well
and the best one of the good things
about webassembly that that it works
seamlessly with web
so there is no additional cost that you
need to pay in order to run web assembly
once you compile it you can just run in
the browser
and some of the use cases of web
assembly and i'm pretty sure that a lot
of you already heard about
assembly because it's already here for a
few years and
usually when we talk about web assembly
we hear some kind of
use cases for facial recognition you
know video games it's a it's a very
uh i think um quite a lot
usage in video games for web assembly
virtual reality on or some
sort of image or video optimization etc
but you know i kind of have a problem
with that because
i think a lot of us well most of the
developers
don't get to work in our day-to-day
basis with this
technologies or with video games or
maybe some kind of
arvr processing and stuff like that and
a lot of us
actually work in enterprise so then you
ask yourself a question well
should i know web assembly and uh should
i should i learn this
and can it be also useful um
in my day-to-day job and hopefully this
talk will
convince you that the answer to this
question is yes
and where can we actually use
webassembly in enterprise well
some of the stuff that were mentioned
here is
data processing is a very common use
case i would say
file and file transfer file processing
file transfer
it's also very common to use a web
assembly and today we will be covering
uh
this three first points some of the
other stuff that i kind of
have in mind is for example sorting or
when you have some critical performance
optimization
you can actually leverage web assembly
to improve overall performance or
responsiveness of your application
so let's
maybe not to talk too much about the
theory let's see some things in practice
and how this is going to look like so
here i have some kind of a very simple
web app and we will quickly show what
what this does
so as i mentioned we're going to talk
today about data processing and file
processing
and as many of you know excel is a go-to
tool
in in small but also big corporations
excel and csv files i think it's very
common and i think all of us kind of uh
once at least once in our careers
encountered this
so here i have two excel files let's
just quickly glance at the data how it
looks like
and uh what are we going to do uh with
this data
so here i have some kind of uh it's
dummy data but this is actually
a sales record and i i think there are
100 000
records in this csv file so you can see
here we have some kind of a country
items date of disorder unit cost and all
these things
so what are we going to do in this app
is we will be
focusing on three columns that's country
item type
and units sold so one of the common
tasks
in any kind of data processing
application is to summarize data so as
you can see we have a lot of records
here
but for example let's say that the
business wants to know
how many clothes have been selled off
per per country or something like that
so today we are going to focus actually
exactly on that we are going to take one
item type for example clothes and then
try to summarize how many units have
been sold
by country
so let's see that we mentioned clothes
right
we want to know what happens with
clothes and here in this web app i i
have a
few sections here which we'll also cover
but there are also here a few buttons
which
uh do some some things um since i'm
comparing rust and js we are going to
take
uh load this file uh process it and
summarize data
and show it in a bar chart so let's
let's
start with js and see how much time do
we need to process this csv
for 100 000 records
so if i load it here and we get a bar
chart and for
example we can see that a lot of clothes
are selling
uia of course this is dummy data but i
think this part is
actually the most important one it's a
performance core table and we can see
that it took
for this task in javascript it took
almo well a bit less than a second
so overall i would say that that's good
for 100 000 records
but let's see rust let's see how rust
compares to javascript
for the same for the same task
so we're doing the same thing here
and again you see that i i have
the same data here however we can see
that
rust kind of is up almost twice twice um
two times slower than javascript
so what happened um you guys are
probably wondering like this guy just
five minutes ago he said that
webassembly is super fast and efficient
but
javascript kicked ass with this file
processing
well today we are also going to learn
some lessons
um about web assembly well actually
there will be only two lessons but they
are very important
and i i really want you guys to
try to remember them because if you're
working with web assembly there are some
things that you need to be aware of
the way how you design your applications
so first lesson is uh web assembly only
understands numbers
so what what does that actually mean
let's
go a little bit deeper here i will
quickly switch to the code so that you
get guys can see what happens
in there as well so
let's compare it here
so on the left side we have some rust
code and on the right side we have some
js code
so essentially i kind of do the same
thing in the beginning
i use this papa papa is a csv parsing
library
so i i just load the file use it in this
use this pop-up arts library to parse
the csv and then here i for example pass
in my data
to the web assembly so this is the part
the webassembly part
for the js i also do the same thing
right i parse the file and then i'm
using d2l library to do all this
summarization and then show it in the
in the chart afterwards so the important
aspect here is this pop-up parse
uh the thing that is passed to the web
assembly is actually an array of
javascript
object so just keep that in mind
so let's see what what happens there
actually and why
webassembly didn't perform well
so as i said webassembly only
understands number but
i just said that when i load the file i
parse i parse
it and then i send it to the an array of
javascript objects
so what happens in the meantime uh there
is this library which is called
vassam bindgen and this library is kind
of a
generates a boilerplate code for you so
you still as you saw in my code i still
work with javascript objects i still
work with something that's familiar i
never turn these things into numbers
that's what actually wasn't binding does
for me general
automatically generates this code which
does the translation part
so what happens here exactly is when i
have this array of js
objects the first thing that happens to
these objects they are stringified
so we turn them into a string first and
then this string
is turned into a number and then as i
said remember lesson number one
web assembly can only understand numbers
then we can pass it on down to the web
assembly
and then we turn these numbers into a
rust struct
struct is stands for structure and maybe
people from who are coming from java or
or c c sharp a world is actually
something like a class so we turn this
into something that's familiar to rust
then we do our processing and return the
result back back to the
js so as you saw a lot of things are
going on there
but of course i wouldn't be talking here
today if i
would think that web assemblies is poor
in performance so let's see if we can
improve
or improve on this so here i have a
rust take two and i'm still doing the
same thing
so we'll we'll see later what changed
but i will again load this file and
let's see
oh well that was quite snappier and as
you can see here
it hit the number one in our charts so
400 milliseconds
for processing this so what did i change
actually let's go back to the code
and let's see in the code what happened
here so one of the things now
that is different from previous if you
remember i did the csv parsig
in javascript before passing it to the
web assembly but now i say okay
well rust also has csv processing
libraries why wouldn't i leverage this
and
do the csv parsing and this process
inside of the web assembly and this is
actually what i what i do
i just load the file here and then i i
send
the text the string to the web assembly
so let me go back to the presentation
and show you how that works
so actually now you see that i've kind
of already eliminated one step
before i had to turn these js objects
into a string
and then the string into a number and
then i can do my processing
but now i'm doing it uh i'm taking a
different approach here
so i immediately load this text as a the
csv file as a text
then vassan binding will turn it into a
number for me i pass it to webassembly
and now this i added some new steps to
the to my web assembly model
i use the uh rust already has libraries
for csv parsing and i do this processing
inside of the
module again i transform it into
something that it's
familiar to rust execute and return
and you actually saw that this has a
huge
implication on my on my speed of the
speed of my
application but there is also
if you saw here in my web app i actually
have a third option as well
so can we even take this further can we
even further improve this performance
let's see what happens and let's see how
it compares to the previous approaches
so again same thing i'm loading the csv
file
and sending it to my webassembly module
and you can see that it
it just got faster now it's 200
milliseconds
so what do i do differently in this
third approach
well as mentioned
maybe show it first in the presentation
and see so i said
very important lesson again guys uh
webassembly only understands numbers
and instead of me first of all
converting this js
objects or maybe loading the file as a
string i immediately load it as bytes as
numbers
and of course this i can immediately
send it to webassembly
turn these bytes into some values that i
can work with
execute the code and return it so
if you look back at the code
same thing happens right but if you look
at our rust code
and these are the three functions that i
call here
so funny thing is if you if you look at
it this first function here
this is the least performant one but it
has the least amount of code only two
lines but it performs very bad as we saw
and then this middle one a bit more code
but still performs better
and then actually here the third one it
has
most lines of code but i think these ten
ten slides of course are really uh
really worth it and if we see our js
part
of of this application here we can see
when we load the file
file is actually in javascript loaded as
something known as blob
and blob exposes a method which is known
as an array buffer which is
actually just binary numbers and then
this is something that you you can pass
down
to your webassembly module
so jumping back to the presentation
lesson number one as we saw
and i kind of rephrased it here whenever
you can
talk with webassembly in the numbers
because as we saw it really
impacts the performance of of your of
your web assembly module
so lesson number two doesn't have to do
exactly with how you load your
data or process it it's actually more on
the way how you design your application
so i called it don't cross the
javascript wasn't border
often but what does that actually mean
what do i mean by that
well the thing is because of technical
reasons
javascript has its own memory
and webassembly has its own memory and
js memory can actually read and write
into the webassembly memory
but the other way around it's not
possible so webassembly doesn't have
access to js memory
and when you want to do something like
for example in my case i wanted to
process some
some records some some file or or any
type of data
i first needed to load this into the web
assembly model
so this is what i mean crossing the
border every time when you want to
process something
every time when you want to send data to
webassembly module this means crossing
the border
and as we saw if you are setting for
example objects you are going to pay a
big price for this think of it as a as a
pay toll on a bridge
every time when you want to cross the
bridge you need to pay
the toll and it's the same here and
one of the approaches well of course
that doesn't mean that we
we still have to you know copy over the
data to the webassembly memory
of course we need something to work with
um but uh
but a good uh good rule of thumb here is
that
when you want to do this copy the data
once
and then keep it in webassembly memory
and do your computation there and just
return the result
just return back the result and i think
that's a very
kind of good pattern to have in mind
when when building
web applications that that run on um
on webassembly modules
so those are the two examples um
i fortunately have to be cautious
of time so i want to have if you if you
look at my app there
uh i have a third example for
compression
uh the call the code will be shared
afterwards so you guys can um
look look in that into more detail but
just a brief what happens here is like
the
the second use case as we mentioned is
um
we in enterprise there's a lot of files
so if we want to process these files
usually we sometimes need to send them
over to the server
and compression can be very useful of
course we all know
for compression but in most of the web
application it goes from the server to
the client
so for example gzip or broadly we send
some asset
gzipped over the network the browser
decompress it decompresses this
and then we can load the application but
with web assembly we actually now have a
different
uh we can we can make this approach
working two ways we can actually
compress some stuff
on the on the web app itself send it
over to the network and then decompress
it on the server
this actually gives us the benefit of
first of all saving some bandwidth for
the user
uh because we are decompressing this
file and also it can improve
significantly the responsiveness and the
user experience because
for example if you if you are running on
a poor network or
um your upload is is not that the
greatest and if you need to upload a 20
megabyte file
this can actually take a significant
time so webassembly can help you there
and decrease this so there is an example
in the repo
if you guys are interested have a look
afterwards and see
if you can use this in your next project
um
so what are the some actually benefits
of of
using uh web assembly in enterprise
well as you guys saw it before it's it's
very fast
if done properly right it can it can
significantly improve uh performance of
your application
uh the other thing is uh i think a lot
of people
um the focus on assembly is actually
performance when people talk about
webassembly it's
performance performance but there is
this other thing which is i think it's
very important and
kind of not doesn't have enough
attention
actually this can save your server costs
why
because the the whole thing all this
processing that we just did
they they are done on the client inside
the browser
so this means that you don't have to you
know upload the file
send it over to the server and then for
example pay
some money to aws to store this
file to process it and then return the
result basically you eliminate this step
completely and you actually use the cpu
from the user's machine or or a phone
and it can actually it can significantly
save you some costs
third benefit is it works offline and
for example if you sometimes like in
this
scenarios where we need to process some
file or do something
we can still do it offline and then for
example when we have a network
connection then we can send the results
to the server
it really depends on your use case and
the type of application
that you have another great thing is
that
we can use the libraries that are
provided by rest and see community
so uh rust is a is a great language
and see i mean of course we all know c
it's been around for
decades now and some of the problems
have been already solved in these
communities in these languages
maybe not in javascript right but you
can still leverage these libraries and
these
problem solving skills and you can use
them out of the box in your web
application
and one benefit today we have typescript
which kind of gets close to being a
statically typed language
but i still think it's not the same
compared to some
something like rust so for example if
you sometimes miss
having a statically typed language in
your day-to-day work
you can use for example rust to to build
um
some web assembly modules and use them
in your web applications
and from my experience with working with
webassembly for some time now
is the state it's
i think it's good as you as you guys saw
we we can already use these things in
our application
it's there it's already been around for
a few years
um and there are a lot of tools in it uh
but
one of the things that i kind of my my
experience is that the tools are still
not there um
for example you saw this wasn't binding
uh library which does
tons of work for you uh but however if
you have some kind of specific
use cases or or something is not working
it can happen that you you need to go a
bit deeper or maybe
uh check the github issues or maybe
check the source code of the library to
try to find
something that works and also i think
developers coming from the javascript of
web development workflows
i think we're a little bit a little bit
spoiled with this react and all these
things for example because you have the
create
react app cli all these cli's and you
just run one two commands and everything
is magically generated for you
webassembly rust has has
similar tools but i i still think it's
not one one two commands
sometimes you need to do a bit more and
you need to do a bit more pump plumbing
um to get it working but the tools are
there and i
think they are ready for production
because there are numer
numerous cases of companies that have
that have leveraged the web assembly uh
in their
product production environments for
example
if anyone is familiar with figma the
tool for for design
systems uh they actually use webassembly
to for for their web application
the second point that i would like to
raise is that as we saw from the two
lessons that i mentioned
you need to be very careful careful how
you plan
and design your code because this can
have an impact and as you saw if you're
if you're
unsure what are you doing if you're just
passing objects around
that you will pay the penalty and uh
this will um this will not turn out well
so you need to take into the
consideration what kind of data do you
have
what's being transferred between uh
javascript or web assembly
and uh take that into consideration when
building your
web applications and the third point
which
it's kind of a double-edged sword i
would say um
learning rust um as you saw i did this
in in
rust and i had been learning rust more
or less for one and a half years now
sometimes more sometimes i haven't done
anything in
a few months and
rust is an awesome language and if you
look at some surveys for example on
stack overflow you will see that it's
the most beloved language at the moment
and there is actually a reason a reason
for this um once you want to start
working with rust you will
realize that but there is also a steep
learning curve
to rust because i
i know other languages and sometimes
when you
when you get in touch with a new
language or trying to learn a new
language you can easily for example
replicate some stuff
so for example if you know python you
can replicate some stuff
if you're starting to learn java or
javascript or something like that
but with written rust i think this
replication level was
quite quite low because rust is
it's hard and
and it really forces you but i think
this is the only language that i have
used so far
uh which forces you to think more about
your code and about
the design of your application because
it's a
statically compiled language and it's
quite
frustrating a lot of times that your
code will not compile
and just show errors the compiler is
very strict but i think
once you compile your code actually
these errors that you saw
actually are forcing you to restructure
application because when you look at
your code and you say oh okay maybe i
can restructure this differently or
maybe i need don't need to pass these
things around
um maybe i could do it differently and
then once you compile
you're guaranteeing that that you're
that your core you have a very
very strong security that your code
will will run properly and
and in general i would recommend
everyone but just keep in mind that if
you want to go the
in this direction you have to invest
sometimes into
learning rust go is also able to compile
to
webassembly and of course if you know c
from before
you can also use this to build your web
assembly modules
so after this uh 25 minutes i would say
you are maybe probably wondering like
should i still
learn uh webassembly well if you weren't
convinced uh by this
i i can i can again reiterate and say
well yes you you should
you should learn webassembly i think
it's a nice
addition to your toolkit and you can use
this for some specific problems
um maybe smaller scale scale problems
but it
it can still be very beneficial for you
to
write better web applications um
so one of the reasons why i think you
should learn it as well
is what also comes in the future so
webassembly you have to understand it
it's very new i think it started 2015
by mozilla mozilla is the main driver
behind this
but now actually rust has a their own
foundation and they're building this
independency from all other
major browsers and
web assembly is constantly being
improved
so one of the things that is going to
land i think soon is multi-threading
so this actually gives us even more
power in our hands
we will be able to use multiple threads
to run our applications and
maybe to do even uh more serious
computations in the browser
interface types i think this is a very
interesting thing
um because it essentially means that the
example that i showed that web assembly
only talks in numbers
this is about to change with the
interface types
so we won't have this boilerplate code
anymore we don't we want in this
intermediate libraries that do the
translation from javascript objects to
to numbers for example this will be
already
kind of hard coded inside of the web
assembly itself
so you will be just able to pass the
your javascript objects
to your webassembly module and this
translation will be done uh
automatically
inside um memory improvements i talked
about
um javascript and mobile assembly having
two separate memories
this is also going to change in the
future i don't think they will merge
these memories
but i think uh web assembly memory will
have more responsibilities and
it will be easier for these two memories
to interact with each other
and one of the things that i think it's
going to make web assembly
let's say more broadly
accepted is portability from other
languages
what does that mean so uh in the
beginning we only had c
and rust so these two languages you can
write code in these two languages and
you can compile them to webassembly as i
said webassembly is a binary format
so now you can use these three languages
to
compile to to webassembly but
there are some projects currently are
going which will allow other languages
to also compile to webassembly so for
example java
java is a very popular language i think
a lot of people know it
and i think this kind of introduction
step to webassembly it's going to be
much much smaller the footprint is going
to be much smaller because you will be
able to
write your own language in your language
that you are familiar with and then just
compile it to webassembly it will
magically uh
run inside your browser and with the
interface types as well it will be
possible to
for example write one web assembly in
java
another web assembly in uh let's say
rust and these web assemblies will be
able to communicate with each other
without any knowledge you know of java
rust
there will be a great portability uh
between them
and what i think will also happen is
that some of the js frameworks or
libraries will move some heavy
computations into the web assembly so
example of this can be react so if you
know react and the virtual dom how this
works
uh uh i think it's a heavy computation
and
to to determine such things what what
changes on the page
um um it's quite heavy and i think some
of this stuff will be
moved into the web assembly so do the
heavy computation there and then
for example um return the result and
soon you can actually already access dom
from web assembly
but i think in the future this uh
accessibility to dom
will be even easier so i would say
great times ahead uh if you're still
thinking about it
don't think twice and maybe start
spending some time learning webassembly
so that will be all from me my name is
nemanja
i work for this company called tsuke for
a few years already
so if somebody is actually looking for a
job i think we are
hiring at the moment so you can approach
me if you are interested
and if you would like to know in more in
general about web assembly or anything
related to web
reach out to me drop me an email
github this web application that we saw
uh
is available on github i will share the
link and
yeah thank you for listening hopefully
talk to you guys soon any questions
yeah i did i actually i'm looking for a
job and i did apply to your company i
think
but i don't i didn't hear back from them
anyway that's besides the point
my question for you is like can i use it
to
do uh you know rust to do restful apis
and all that would that
be a performance improvement over web
sockets in javascript or
how would that pan out uh good question
uh so
i don't think you can so the web
assembly module doesn't have access to
all the
apis that are provided by the browser so
i think
the the for the http i don't think it's
provided to the webassembly module
but if you know about fetch javascript
fetch you can call
fetch from webassembly and you can you
can make your rest call
to be honest this doesn't uh i i don't
think it's a
an improvement uh because you still you
will still
um make this request right uh but
sometimes you will you will be maybe
maybe able to save this uh
this um you don't need to cross the
border between the
javascript web assembly so it is
possible but i think in the future it's
going to be even more easier to make
these
web requests and do your processing in
the webassembly module
yeah if you have to go from javascript
to rust to javascript back it doesn't
make any sense at all
depends depends on your use case right
if you if you if you
need to use this data afterwards in your
javascript for example to show it on the
screen or something like that
then it doesn't make sense to keep it in
the web assembly so you can just
transfer it to the computation and
return the results
and then just continue processing
processing in in javascript
i would say it really depends on your
use case and
what kind of problem are you trying to
solve correct yeah thanks
um you said we could we could use some
existing c software uh from the c
community or the rust community and
convert into wasm
i'm just um thinking if you so if we had
a c program we wanted to use it
um in wasdem would we also need the
source code to all of the libraries
so we can compile it all at the same
time
uh no actually i can quickly show you
that how that works
so for example i only i only have one
rust file here and this is where all my
code
lies and here on the top you see that
for example i
import some libraries um
so i don't know plate 2 compression this
is a compression library that i used
and it's available uh in rust
and rust has something it's called cargo
tumble cargo is a package manager for uh
rasta applications
and the uh i mean uh we're all familiar
we are all familiar with npm
um cargo is the same thing basically
well i think much better version because
it handles dependencies much better
but here you you just declare your
dependencies right and for example you
see here i use the csv uh library for
for the
for the processing of my file and i use
this plate to compression library
and uh cargo will when you when you
compile
your your ros code it will pull pulley
down
and uh it will it will compile all the
things for you
so uh you you don't have to go to the
source code or or
do any additional uh stuff there
okay that's great thank you
when you said well some deals only with
numbers um i guess you mean
it deals with bytes uh
is it like um a 64 byte
language sorry 64 bit
oh good question i am i'm not sure
but i can actually show you what kind of
a boilerplate code happens
uh what kind of a boilerplate code is
generated by the
by the um by the wasam
binding library so you can see here for
example we
we we work
they work a lot of with pointers and all
this stuff so they they put it on the
stack
and then here for example we take from
the memory so this
this code here is automatically uh
generated i'm not sure i can i can check
for you
but but i'm i'm not sure of what kind of
bites
are we talking about okay
but it saves you a lot of time because
you don't have to you know
instantiate the memory and for example
you see here
people who know c malloc it means memory
allocation allocate so some of the stuff
it's already done for us
and but i think in the future this this
will also disappear it will be
completely
hidden from our application
any more questions this doesn't look
like c at all uh you said
uh or if i write in c it'll compile to
rust or something or it'll compile to a
no no
this here that you see is a js file so
this is javascript so it doesn't have to
do with
this is just so this code is loaded by
javascript and
the the javascript is the part which
does this translation from
a javascript object to a number and then
the number is passed to the web assembly
module so this is this is still
javascript no no c
whatsoever so is this a library we're
looking at now
or compiled code no this is compiled
code
so if you if you if i show you my ras
code
just a second if i show you my ras code
and the only thing that you need to do
for example here i have i have a
class which is called sales record store
and i just need to annotate it with this
vason binden
so wasan bindon is the library which
automatically generates
this this code and it will be handled
handled by me
and then in my js code for example here
you can see that i instantiate so i call
my module
i import it and then i start instantiate
this class
and then i can call any any method on
this class basically
so if i go back to the to the to rust
you can see here that this is the new
it's actually like a
constructor and here you can see see my
methods
and since the class is annotated with
the vason
all this code here will be automatically
generated for us
so we don't have to do anything it does
a lot of heavy lifting and
i i think it's a quite quite a relief
for for development okay for this sorry
this is this compiled file uh is then
the bridge from javascript
to wasm or is everything in here or is
it just the
just making the bridge uh this is just
this is just the bridge
it's just making the bridge okay
but even your uh rust code doesn't look
like
c plus plus like impul and all that this
is not c plus
is not c no i i i just mentioned you can
do stuff in c but i don't have any c
libraries here so this all the whole
project is
specifically written in rust and i would
advise to use rust compared to c because
rust is
first of all statically typed and a much
better job at memory handling and all
these things
so if you can you use use rust compared
to c so c
use case for c is only if you have an
existing code in c
and then then you want to use it in your
your javascript application but if
you're writing new code i would suggest
rustle or maybe go as languages
thanks and this is actually you can see
one of the pattern that i mentioned
without crossing the border too often
you can see when i instantiate
my class here i have a like a private
property of sales records so this is
where i store my data
and when i load it i just store it in
this variable
and then actually i have a separate
method which i haven't exposed
well actually i did sorry i'm lying i
did expose it
but uh did this this method doesn't take
data it just takes the item type and
then you know iterates over that data
and does the
summarization of it so you can you can
keep your stuff in your
webassembly memory and then do
processing on top of it
the three ways you pass the data in your
tests
you passed a json string then you tried
passing a plain string
and then you passed a binary just the
binary data
and then you say in the future we might
be able to be interface types we might
be able to pass
structured data across do you think that
that seems like the ideal way to me
because you
probably have your data structured in
javascript already and you'd like to
pass it over structured
do you think that will be fast or maybe
even faster because there won't be any
pausing after it's been passed well
good question whatever it will be faster
because you still you still need to
convert the objects into numbers somehow
right
and the thing is i think this
translation will still happen
but i think if it's done on the web
assembly side probably it's going to be
a way optimized or maybe they will i'm
not sure about the
implementation of this but maybe they
will add some you know
magic code in the in the browser engines
or in the web assembly itself
which will do make this translate
translation uh
faster so now we really need to think
about this
and you see here for example this is
something it's a it's a js value right
it's
not an in in my javascript code this is
an array of js objects but here it's a
js value
this is just the type which is provided
by the web
of this wasan banjon library so
it's kind of a generic value let's say
and and then vason binden will know
uh what happens here and it will be
in this line here it will be uh able to
turn my objects into
um a vector on an array of of of
of my uh rust kind of a structure here
okay
but if you can especially with files as
you saw passing the
the array buffer here when you read the
file directly
and it will it will just make your lives
easier and
anytime actually when you can pass
numbers do do that
because it's much more performant
and actually i forgot to mention that
this scales very nice
because in the in the first file we had
like uh one uh
100 thousand records so
if i process a file with million records
it just gets faster so this other file
that i just
loaded now it has one million records
and you can see for example here it only
takes uh
two seconds and with javascript i i
think it's around nine ten seconds
uh to to make this work so web assembly
it's made for big problems i would say
but still you can use it for for smaller
optimizations as well
you mentioned that the only use case for
using c
is you have some existing code right so
how well
uh rust versus go do you have any
advice on that um good questions i
i haven't used go i i am not familiar
with the language
itself go is also new i know some people
here i think in singapore in general go
go i think is very
famous with some startups so i i spoke
with some people
that for example migrated from java to
go and
one of the biggest problems that they
have it they say that uh
libraries are uh there are not
a lot of available libraries so for
example let's say
i don't know i'm making up now but date
handling or for example this csv
processing or some some problems that
have been already solved in in these
more popular languages
are not there and go and then you end up
you you have to write your own stuff
so i think go is still new russ has been
around
for some quite quite some time and i
think the benefit of
of rust compared to go would be that a
lot of
c programmers are actually now migrating
to rust so rust is not only used
it's actually more used in for example
embedded software and
building something closer to the
hardware
and because of this and because of the
big community i think a lot of libraries
from c have been ported over
to rust so i don't know much about about
go but i would say
because of what i what these things that
i've kind of heard from other people
i think maybe rust would be more uh
appropriate
um for for these libraries and also you
cannot use all libraries for so for
example
webassembly can access file system yet
so if you want to load a file from file
system you you cannot do this so the the
entry point needs to be
you pass it in the numbers or or in some
kind of other other format but you
cannot read the file directly from the
file system
i was going to say in terms of languages
you can also use c sharp because
on the dot net world you also have the
opportunity of using web assembly with
blazer
correct correct that's also true uh
microsoft has a blazer framework
i'm also not familiar haven't used it
but i know about it so
i think it's also as i said i think it's
going to be even more broader in the
future
when you start writing java and then
compile it to webassembly
so i think then again you know it's
going to pick up and
people that are familiar with their
their
comfortable in their their language can
use it to immediately compile to
webassembly
but javascript uh oh sorry java compiles
to
i mean it needs a java runtime jvm right
uh how is that going
i mean it's gonna be very heavy yeah
good one good one i i know there are
projects currently that are
doing this so maybe
they will eliminate this part or or kind
of make the
footprint of the jvm smaller not not
sure
but there is an ongoing work for this i
think the one with the
c-sharp.net one the uh runtime there is
about
617k
just to give a i know that that world
there that's how large
their runtime is oh that's yeah
and they are using i think the core
runtime.net core yes
okay yeah so as you can see it's still
you know possible
um but let's see how it unfolds
so obviously this web module wasm
is downloaded uh you know like if i'm if
i if i
if i go to browse to a site which
actually uses it it'll be downloaded and
then used and then discarded
correct and it's not discarded it's just
as any other file that you send
over the network so if you can see here
on the on the left side
you have this data vessel file so this
is actually the the binary code
let's see what happens if i open it like
this yeah
it's not it cannot be loaded normally
but this is the
this is the web assembly format and this
file
you send it to the browser and if you
see it here actually
in my web app and you can check out the
code later for more details
but we also need to to load to load this
module on the beginning
so here this is where the loading of the
module happens and it's a promise and
you need to wait for the promise to to
resolve
and then one once the module is loaded
you're good to go i mean it behaves just
as any other asset that you would send
over from the server
okay more questions
could you also do a progressive web app
the pwa
so you effectively had an install like
an installed app
using uh web assembly
okay i mean i'm familiar with the
progressive web apps
but i don't know about the usage of
webassembly
indeed so for to my understanding i mean
the progressive web apps introduce the
service worker leverage
on this to make the caching easier and
all this stuff
but i'm not sure how how how it relates
to web assembly and what would be the
use case i'm just thinking since it's
just basically it's a manifest
and also the worker one as you said you
in theory could actually build
a web application which would be
installable which had a part of it which
is using web assembly
oh yeah i mean yes i i think i think
it's a it's a two different technologies
and two different problems right
you can for example this app you can
make it a pwa and installable
and i don't think it's related to web
assembly in general
uh you can or you cannot use the web
assembly in your web progressive app i i
don't think they are
you know related or need to work without
one another i think they're completely
no they're not they're not related but
you could use them together
that was what i meant oh yeah yeah for
sure for sure um
there are no i think there are no
limitations so the limitations here
are only uh for example you cannot use
as
mentioned all the apis provided by the
browser like file system
and limitation can be for example if the
library that you want
is not available in rust so for example
one of the things that i know rust pour
is and sees
better would be image processing
libraries so if you need like to
compress image or do some kind of
image manipulation i think rust is
limited in that sense it has some some
things
but c is is way better in that area
i wonder if you could write a game and
see and you know
it's possible theoretically right you
know you you don't have to wonder that
these things already exist so if you go
googling i think you will find at least
a lot of examples on this so there are
literally cases for example i know adobe
adobe because a lot of their software i
don't know if it's photoshop or or one
of these tools that that is used for you
know graphics and design
uh a lot of a big portion of it it's uh
uh written in c
and they were the one of the first kind
of big consumers of web assembly
maybe like two three years ago even they
work closely with google to implement
this in the browsers
so they literally took their their c
code and just compiled it to webassembly
and on top of that they just built a ui
a web ui right in javascript and react i
think
and uh under the hood they were reusing
uh their
existing code so they they could already
use it out of the box
so video games or anything or any code
that you have written already in c
there is a great likelihood that you can
already
compile it to webassembly and use it in
your web app cool
so we can have a web app with no
javascript at all
anymore that that's actually kind of um
one of the topics that people are saying
oh webassembly is going to you know
replace javascript but i don't think
this is going to happen
because i think they solve kind of
different problems um
there are actually some frameworks react
like frameworks where you can write your
html and all this stuff inside of the
inside of rust
and this will be then generated as a web
app
but i i think i i'm not sure if this is
smart enough i think what javascript or
web does very good is
this separation of concern where you
have your html and
this presentational layer is kind of
separated from the
other things and i think the tools
around this are
far better than in rust so i i i only
see the kind of a future where these two
things
will cooperate so you will do the heavy
stuff in your web
web assembly and i think most of the
stuff will still remain in
in javascript
you're writing it'll be interesting
writing dom manipulation in c
yeah let's see
i know c by the way i i live in breed c
and c plus plus
i used to do c but uh i think if i was
to do something at that level now i
would probably try rust
because i hear rust is the new great
yep i i fully recommend rust beautiful
language
i said it's a bit harder to learn but
there are some good tools and i think
their communities
is very good and for sure guys you can
you can use this
to learn it i will share the link
to the the web app in the chat
so you guys can have a look i mean and
if you guys have any questions about
this just
you know reach out to me and always
willing to discuss
okay amanda thanks a lot for your talk
and for your
for answering our questions